im kanzleramt hat man sich etwas neues
ausgedacht ich glaube es ist das letzte
muskelspiel der bundeskanzlerin gut vier
wochen vor der bundestagswahl es geht um
3g es geht um die deutsche bahn es geht
um lufthansa das geht eigentlich darum
wie wir künftig reisen sollen ziel der
bundeskanzlerin ziel des kanzleramt es
ist dass künftig in allen zügen der
deutschen bahn und auch in der lufthansa
auf inlandsflügen 3 gelten soll das
heißt befördert werden darf nur noch wer
chinesen geimpft oder getestet wurde und
jetzt kommt eine ironie das würde
bedeuten weil die bahn nämlich selbst
gar nicht weiß ob ihre schaffner geimpft
sind das also im zweifel ungeimpfte
schaffner in der bahn die ober
kontrolleur dies gegenüber geimpften
getesteten und genesenen spielen müssen
also ich glaube abgesehen von der
tatsache dass man gar nicht weiß wie man
das überhaupt kontrollieren soll stellen
sich vor ein zug mit 20 waggons bräuchte
dann 40 schaffen an den türen müsste
wahrscheinlich alleine berliner
hauptbahnhof zehn minuten viertelstunde
warten bis alle passagiere kontrolliert
wird also auch das lässt sich logistisch
gar nicht umsetzen und deswegen meine
aufforderung heute abend an den
bundesverkehrsminister andreas scheuer
stoppen sieht diesen essensplan aus dem
kanzleramt das ist natürlich der ist
natürlich willfährig weil er weil er
hofft sich auf ein ministeramt nach der
wahl erhalten zu können das ist ein
irrglaube söder wird im abräumen und so
höchste zeit dass er abgeräumt und muss
den plan aber wir wollen jetzt vier
wochen nicht hat die chance sich darum
kümmern da wird daraus wird auch nichts
aus dem plan herges wir wetten
wenn sie merken dass wir werden erstmal
um den anti steuer und zwar dass er
diesen plan stopp
werden
ich komme zu ihnen nach hause ich weiß
jetzt wo sie wohnen
also was mir durch den kopf geht das
natürlich nicht einer der wichtigsten
wie ich diese figur sondern merkel
merkels autoritäre tendenzen die wir
jetzt schon seit mindestens einem jahr
beobachten können haben jetzt wieder
eine neue drehung genommen es ist
wirklich zeit dass die frau geht das ist
so dieser ostdeutsch autoritärer
gouvernanten haffter art über die
gesellschaft zu entscheiden im
alleingang ohne jemanden zu fragen
sondern eine idee auszuspucken und dann
jemanden zu beauftragen umzusetzen damit
muss schluss sein wir leben in einer
demokratisch organisierten
gesellschaften dahin dass man auch
wieder zurück er gelähmt vor einigen
einer gesellschaft wieder sagen darf
daher mittlerweile jeder zweite
bundesbürger doppelt geimpft ist ja aus
rahn seit 15 monaten in der bahn mit
maske ja und jetzt plötzlich wo die
hälfte der bundesbürger geimpft das
heißt aber jetzt liegen sie zeigen sie
geimpft sind sie vielleicht genießen
oder getastet hier als klassisches durch
den kopf gegangen ist bei dieser
geschichte war auch die union ist ja
noch über 20 jahren
verlieren da kann man noch mal fünf
prozent runtergehen dann ist er olaf
scholz bei 27 mal die wir besser ist
nach
um gerne der störfaktoren diese
diskussion auch mich stört viele solche
maßnahmen aber wir leben eine pandemie
zeit und als vater von einem kind der
gerade eingeschult ist will ich alles
tun damit unsere kinder zur schule
weitergehen und ich befürchte in einem
monat haben wir in diskussionen nicht
über den bahn fahren sondern über die
schulen und ich bin psychologe und weiß
in den letzten monaten und erlebte auch
so viele menschen mit familien und
kindern die komplett untergegangen sind
die ihre bildungskarriere beendet haben
muss man in aller deutlichkeit sagen
menschen die an psychischen störungen
leiden übergewicht kaum bewegungen
konsum von medien das sind alle
nebenwirkungen oder folgen von diesen
lockt uns die wir gehabt haben und ich
befürchte wenn wir jetzt nichts tun um
die zahl nach unten zu bringen wenn wir
nichts tun damit die impfquote weiter
steigt wenn die kinder darunter leiden
und die kinder haben recht auf
normalität und deshalb zerschnitt ich
mach mit bei 2g sogar hauptsache die
kinder trainieren dabei alles in einer
schale ganz gut sagen dass ihr kind an
der schule beim thema bahn ist es ja
etwas anderes da gibt es die studie eine
neue studie auch offensichtlich wird die
luft in einem waggon innerhalb von
siebeneinhalb minuten einmal komplett
ausgetauscht das bedeutet sie sitzen
eigentlich permanent in frischluft fast
wie draußen und da ist ja die frage und
bin komplett ihrer meinung es darf kein
doktor und für schulen geben überhaupt
nicht das sage ich nicht nur weil ich
sie ist schätze und damit auch natürlich
ihr kind schätze ich habe selbst kinder
und es gibt elf millionen schüler in
deutschland das darf nie wieder
passieren aber wir müssen glaube ich
immer schauen was ist eigentlich
realistisch und was ist sinnvoll dass es
nicht sinnvoll ob andere nicht mutter
aber ich habe trotzdem dazu zwei
gedanken gehabt sofort erster gedanke
stand ja bei bild.de heute das sei schon
am montag im corona kabinett angerissen
worden ganz kurz zurück wo wir haben wir
alle am montag eigentlich nachgedacht
afghanistan und das ist wirklich eine
lage in der wir uns nicht gerade mit
ruhm bekleckert haben und wenn ich jetzt
überlegen wir haben dort außenpolitisch
riesen baustellen wir performen da
wirklich nicht kann es noch vorsichtig
ausgedrückt und die kanzlerin ist aber
eigentlich gar nicht bei dieser sache an
dieser stelle sondern sie beschäftigt
sich mit neuen einschränkungen der
kroner lage wo wir gerade mpk hatten
mehr der unterm strich nicht viel raus
gekommen ist und der andere punkt wenn
wir überlegen wie viele menschen pendeln
in deutschland und zwar wirklich mit dem
pc oder mit dem ic nicht jetzt mit der
s-bahn so und ab oktober sollen die
tests auch selbst bezahlen das heißt die
pendler müssen sich täglich testen das
täglich selbst bezahlen das ist doch
humbug wie sollen denn das überhaupt
funktionieren oder schlicht durch die
hintertür exakt so ist es eigentlich
muss ich will mal grundsätzlich sagen
hermann so ich verstehe ja 100 prozent
ihren ansatz
ich würde nicht mehr tolerieren wollen
dass kinder an den schulen noch
fernunterricht kriegen und mit der maske
rumlaufen die zeit ist endlich gekommen
dass wir unsere freiheitsrechte
zurückbekommen ich will sie wieder haben
ich bin geimpft ich will auch irgendwann
nicht mehr mit einer maske rumrennen
müssen sondern will selbst entscheiden
müssen ob und wo ich die trage dafür ist
es höchste zeit und diese gedanken die
merkel als ostdeutsche autoritäre jetzt
wieder ansteht geht in eine ganz andere
richtung die wirft uns wieder zurück in
debatten die wir eigentlich hinter uns
haben jetzt wir müssen freiheits
debatten führen und ich hoffe es und den
offenen und ich hoffe dass die
bundestagswahl auch eine entscheidung
darüber wird und die koalition die
danach kommt hier immer die
zusammengesetzt ist muss zu diesen
fragen eine grundsatzentscheidung
treffen zu sagen jetzt ist mal schluss
mit den einschränkungen im wesentlichen
jedenfalls und jetzt gilt die verfassung
wider und die und die parlamente kommen
wieder ich referiere reiter ich will die
figur lachen wenn du hast gerade rein
gebracht man hätte es früher machen
müssen dann hätte man es machen der
moment wo wir testen als legitimes
mittel zur pandemie bekämpfung
eingeführt haben ich finde da wird im
moment gewesen dieses jahr jeder platz
bleibt frei in der bahn rp zwei masten
flächen gut aber wenn du es dann nicht
umsetzt und sagst da muss getestet
werden plus wer kontrolliert die tests
ja ist es beim einsteigen wie jan vorhin
gesagt hat oder ist es wirklich der
schaffner der dann sich freut noch eine
aufgabe zu haben aber bei der bahn
funktioniert sowieso nicht viel das muss
man so sagen
doppelmoral den herrscht wir hatten ja
nun ein lokführerstreik über zwei tage
und dann noch mal zwei tage auch gerade
diese woche da gehalten diesen ganzen
masken geregnet plötzlich ja gar nicht
alles ja es gab selbst schaffner via
kollegen auch erzählen die hatten wir
die maske und japan ist jetzt vorbei
sagte einer denn ist pandemie mal für 48
stunden vorbei weil
es wunderbar weil das ist alles nicht
hat irgendwie stichhaltig series lms und
über 90 2 nur ganz kurz dabei hinweise
aber ich will diese garantie diese
schule garantie das recht auf normalität
nicht nach dem wahren ich will das jetzt
von den ohren haute man kaum was dazu
und 2 es gibt auch studien die sagen
solange
nicht die ungeimpften sich bewegen und
sich impfen werden wir immer wieder mit
dieser krankheit was zu tun haben
deshalb ist dieser druck auch wenn es
indirekt ist dass die menschen bitte
sich impfen dann finde ich das legitim
das ist der einzige möglichkeit um
überhaupt diese zahlen ich würde es
anders beschreiben ich glaube wir müssen
ein zurückkommen dass die geimpften
vorteile vom impfen haben ich kann mich
nicht erinnern dass ich jetzt überhaupt
einen impfausweis er zeigen musste in
den letzten monaten weil mir das
nirgendwo mehr abverlangt wird möchte
ich aber eigentlich gerne vorher in die
ungeimpften sehen dass man mit anja
impfausweis irgendwo in der bahn
beispielsweise wenn es so käme keine
maske mehr tragen muss also wenn es so
käme wie man merkel will dann will ich
auch
abteil keine maske mehr tragen denn dann
sitzen ja nur saubere leute da drin
mache ich nicht mehr vier stunden ece
miteinanders wir sehen es ja bei der
bundeskanzlerin aus sie ist doppelt
geimpft und trifft sich mit einem an das
doppel kämpften politiker wir brauchen
gar keine namen sondern beide begrüßen
sich mit maske und mit ellbogencheck
also es gibt offenbar eine große angst
aber in diesem angst korsett ist die
kanzlerin gefallen und noch ein punkt
zum thema 3g in der bahn das ist das
beste verstopfung programm für die
autobahn denn genau der punkt ist ja wer
sich nicht impfen lassen will lässt sich
jetzt auch da nicht jeden tag und es
sonst einfach alles klappt wunderbar
dann setze ich mich wieder ins auto
fabia 1 nach oben oder nach unten oder
auf der a3 oder wie auch immer und stets
schon im stau macht genau das was die
bundesregierung auf flächen dann wird
nämlich noch mehr co2 in die luft zu
bleiben also ich glaube das ist alles
überhaupt nicht durchdacht und es ist
das letzte muskelspiel der kanzlerin
aber es hat scheint eigentlich alleine
wert steht